mon projet vise à trouver une méthode
qui va permettre l'identification du
tatouage est facile on prend l'apéro
muscles et tatouages son identifiant sur
une personne
expliquant aux policiers peuvent s'en
servir pour identifier les personnes que
soit leur domicile ou les catastrophes
naturelles
notre but c'est de trouver une méthode
qui s'applique à un être vivant donc il
n'est pas toxique pour la personne on a
décidé d'y aller avec les pis le curcuma
qui est une épice région qui colore
beaucoup et environs des pistolets voir
on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait une
grande fleur essence associé à la
curcumine qui est la molécule du curcuma
on est parti de là et on va faire les
quelques dérivés de la curcumine qu'on
va pouvoir tester dans un futur proche
sur des humains pour voir si le
contraste entre le tatouage effacés et
la course normale est assez grande pour
qu'on puisse leur mari